union avec un ciel le plus souvent
nuageux et couvert quelques averses qui
seront attendus à nouveau sur la moitié
est du département ainsi que les eaux du
sud ouest comme la plaine des mac ou
encore le tampon des plages de l'ouest
en revanche on en garde et de belles
éclaircies jusqu'à 30 degrés sur les
côtes 30 pour le port 29 degrés pour
saint-pierre et quelques petites gouttes
16 degrés prévus pour le maïdo c'était
la météo avec sirius fabricant de
chauffe eau solaires à la réunion et
c'est l'heure de retrouver votre lundi
politique avec voguait le dantec votre
invité la france insoumise jean hugues
ratenon
bonjour j'ai six bonjour à tous l lundi
politique
gaël le dantec la dernière semaine de
campagne avant le scrutin européen
dimanche soir tous les électeurs de
toute l'europe de l'union européenne
parmi les 645 millions choisi leurs
représentants au parlement européen il
n'y aura qu'un seul tour
les députés européens sont élus à la
proportionnelle seule hélice qui ont
dépassé les 5% environ des représentants
à strasbourg hus sur ces dix figures
parfois sans doute mais essentiellement
terminé d'ailleurs la liste présentée
par la france
insoumise conduite par mme à l'ambré et
de nous sommes arrivés en quatrième
place seul euro députés réunionnais
sortant et s'ils sont traités ne se
trompe pas trouve devrait retrouver son
siège pour défendre quelles politiques
sociales économiques écologiques pour
promouvoir quelle place pour les outre
mer pour la réunion
c'est jean graton député la france ont
soumis ce qu'il n'est pas réaliste ce
parti sur la première jusqu'à 13 heures
vos questions aux 90 2000 à partir de
12h45
jean graton bonjour je remercie d'avoir
accepté des pots les états unis votre
invitation il ya une fatalité au marc
giraud député sortant pour défendre
cette liste ça veut dire quoi que si
tout le monde est mobilisé dans le jeu
c'est pas bon je vais essayer
de défendre la liste manon brille et
c'est vrai que monsieur you so magie est
en quatrième position les sondages
aujourd'hui donne la liste de la france
est soumise entre 8,5 et 9 6%
je pense que nous allons terminer autour
du titre sont les prévisions donnent aux
poissons au soir du du 26 mai on verra
bien vous avez une ambition particulière
pour chiffrer à nyon je pense qu'il faut
laisser les les réunionnaises et les
réunionnais voter mais ce qui est sûr ce
que notre ambition c'est de mettre la
liste en marche le plus bas possible on
va profiter de tout le monde c'est pas
seulement la responsabilité de la france
est soumise
on va revenir là dessus nous sommes
archi c'est le bon candidat est ce que
ça aurait pas été intéressant de changer
qui reste pas à son poste de député
robert m'a écouté younous omarjee c'est
quoi ces 88 % de présence à la 101e au
parlement européen ça veut dire qu'il
est très très présent c'est un des
parlementaires les plus présents au
parlement c'est 108 heures à pau est un
des rapports votés presqu'à l'unanimité
sur les régions ultrapériphériques
nous sommes à j -c une note 18h20 17h20
c'est à dire que sur pour la défense des
océans
younous omarjee c'est aussi celui qu'a
eue en 2018 désigné il a été désigné
le meilleur député européen en ce
concerne la défense des régions ces
cantons intervention en plénière
c'est un très très bon technicien il
faut savoir que l'europe
ces politiques mais c'est aussi très
technique et donc il faut il a fait la
démonstration d'un député qui maîtrise
les dossiers faut savoir qu'avant d'être
député européen il était qu' il a
travaillé auprès vergès c'est qu'un cas
quand même qu'ils maîtrisent très bien
les dossiers qui maîtrise les rouages de
l'union européenne dès ce qu'on appelle
les régions ultrapériphériques la place
de la réunion dans dans l'europe il faut
savoir que la réunion comme les autres
régions ultrapériphériques l'europe mais
avec un statut particulier
il faudra travailler encore plus sur cet
aspect là il a gagné une bataille
importante et nous sommes archi
notamment sur le lac électrique vous de
saut de son mandat vous mettriez cole en
avant disons que il y a
la bataille sur la pêche électrique c on
peut quand on regarde comme ça on dit
ouais mais c'est une bataille contre la
pêche électrique la pêche intense mais
c'est surtout une bataille pour la
protection de la planète
il faut savoir quand même et il ya eu
quand même la date du 10 mai où on dit
le 10 mai 2019 l'europe a déjà consommé
ce que la planète peut régénérer en une
année c'est à dire là on vit déjà à
crédit par rapport à ce que la planète
peut nous donner et une son mari est
quelqu'un comme très sûr qu'on va être
très axé sur la protection de la planète
et moi même sur réunion 1ère lors d'une
émission je crois que c'était en soi fin
2007 début soit fin 2011 ou début 2012
je disais dans l'émission de rokhaya sur
réunion 1ère que notre moment il
maintient aussi la terre écrit que notre
moment il ya couche les dépôts zanussi
un autre moment et de ton nom c'est la
planète terre et ne doit protéger comme
maternelle de la protéine moment la
terre et si nous protège pas les nous
les morts travailler et nous nous sommes
ajustés quelqu'un qui est son combat est
très axé sur la protection des êtres et
la protection de la planète
on va reparler second tour et je pense
que on a tout intérêt dans tout ce que
nous faisons chaque jour toujours avoir
dans la tête
il faut protéger la planète
la disparition de l'être humain et de
tous les êtres gilles gratton lors des
dernières élections européennes en 2014
l'abstention était 2 81% et il ya un
réunionnais sur cinq seulement qui s'est
déplacé pour voter
ce manque d'intérêt
oui et non là est notre responsabilité
aux six mois vous savez moi je suis né
dans une famille très militante et je me
rappelle mon papa disait toujours où ça
gagne l'âge pour aller voter il faudra
voter
après à vous de voir ou qui ça au vote
mais après les leaders weng aucun
petites phrases après mais sous votre là
les biens n'a pas eu de voix conséquents
mais voilà un petit coin aussi parce que
le vote c'est extrêmement important et
faut savoir que les femmes l'a eu le
droit de vote beaucoup plus longtemps
que les hommes et ça a été un combat
intense c'est la démocratie
c'est l'expression maintenant moi je dis
aux gens et parmi mes proches
il y en a qui souhaitent pas voté jeudi
ben écoute en dernier ressort si parmi
les lisières personnes qui s'y trouvent
et quand même 34 6 34 lisent donc il ya
le choix mais s'il n'y a pas de listes
qui correspond à des convictions mais au
moins aller voter que le bulletin nul
mais est-ce que ça sert à quelque chose
allait voter pour cette élection là
qu'est ce que vous dites vous aux gens
j'ai envie qu'on est allés voter soit en
euros bien sûr qu'est ce que cette
entrée dans l'élection européenne
le grand le nouveau dg les jeunes que ce
soit sur le plan national mais ici à la
réunion et encore plus à la réunion j'ai
donne à nous la parole d'un anneau le
moyen d'esprit manou et notamment la
revendication principale c'était le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne zurich
et et c'est vrai que l'or dans son rendu
du grand débat emmanuel macron
a clairement dit qu'il n'était pas
politique mais l'été pour référendum
partager amélioré qui est totalement
différent du rich
mais on peut dire qu'il ya eu quand même
une petite évolution il y aura une
position régionale d'ailleurs de voilà
donc à nous de voir comment s'approprier
sa mais l'élection européenne
c'est aussi un référendum pourquoi parce
que le président de la république
lui-même entre dans la bataille
électorale
donc ce n'est plus le président de tous
les français mais c'est un chef de parti
et sa photo est sûre la le bulletin de
propagande la profession de foi on le
voit sur les affiches
il prend position il intervient dans les
meetings est clairement qu est ce qu il
dit aux françaises et français
si vous êtes d'accord avec ma politique
voter pour la liste hommage conduite par
madame loiseau et puis si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord bon ben voilà donc ça veut
dire quoi
ça veut dire que si nous voulons le
sanctionner et si nous voulons passer un
message très fort trenet très ferme à
emmanuel macron il faut aller voter il
faut aller voter transformer ou savent
bien que ce vote on recentre revoir pour
les européennes
j'ai dit voilà un aspect il ya aussi
l'aspect programmatique
le programme l'europe c'est quoi mais
permettez moi d'insister sur cet aspect
[Musique]
référendum que ce soit sur le plan
national de toute façon on l'entend sur
le plan national je pense que nous
allons voter au taux de 40 45 poisson 40
pesos on aura un taux de participation
beaucoup plus élevée qu'à la réunion ce
sont les prévisions mais beaucoup vont
voter pas seulement pour le programme
pas seulement point sur la ligne
idéologique mais aussi pour sanctionner
ou approuver la politique des manières
mâcon est ce que c'est un peu dommage
d'utiliser ce scrutin pour une dimension
politique nationale sur la politique
européenne est en jeu pour cela que de
rester chez soi des diamants n'est pas
là que ça il faut être là et que ça
parce que la politique du pas là et ça
c'est une politique ou paye cash après
et donc moi je prône aussi cela et lors
d'une conférence de presse sir je les
dis quand je vois par exemple
bon je termine sur l'aspect national
orientations nationales
il faut aussi en dehors du programme
il faut aussi utiliser cette élection un
pour sanctionner macro plus il y aura de
votants plus le score des manuels marron
et d'un mois se rabat sur aux yeux en
faisant en faisant
de ce que tu as fait un contre
contrairement à ce que vous risquez pas
pousser les électeurs à voter pour le
rassemblement exactement la même chose
disent ces deux l'occasion de
sanctionner appris que des manuels macro
al almi s'attend pour dire votre vote
utile pour sanctionner marrant c'est le
vôtre à son inauguration puisqu'ils sont
au coude à coude dans les sondages 20%
et que nous finalement le rassemblement
le seul poème devant la vache et le
front national
et c'est vrai c'est ce que souhaite
madame le pen oui mais c'est parce que
nous nous souhaitons maintenant le
premier politiques responsables
politiques à dire il faut aussi utiliser
cette élection comme un référendum
il ya plusieurs mois de cela c'est jean
luc mélenchon il faut quand même se
rappeler oui mais ce que le risque sais
pas si c'est pour sanctionner mme à
croître il ya ya combien vous avez parlé
de 33 lits sont à 33 10 94 il ya le
choix maintenant en fonction de ses
convictions
et là aussi entre aussi en jeu les
convictions peut-être là
vous pouvez aborder cet aspect dans le
sens où la liste qui peut passer devant
monsieur manière quand je pense qu'il
sera battu lundi dans ma sera battu de
toute façon ne sera pas en première
position
maintenant le vote il faut savoir quand
même que le vote de la france est
soumise c'est mettre le maximum de
députés européens dans le parlement
européen et pour les lys qui
malheureusement vont pas atteindre la
barre des 5% y/y hors pas de
parlementaires et donc plus on on n'ait
pas pu les voir
- il y aura des députés s'est soumise
plus il y aura de députés front national
est puis sera des députés en marche non
il est extrêmement important de
concentrer aussi un message aux
communistes rennais par exemple abaissé
un message à plusieurs n'avaient pas
voté pour lui bon talent bave et voter
pour une soirée message à tous les
progressistes de gauche à tous les vrais
progressiste par les faux progressiste
parce que il ya l'étiquette mais après
il ya aussi le que le contenu le
progressisme c'est ce dont se
revendiquent eux emmanuel macron pas
seul à la réunion il ya aussi ces textes
romantiques progressisme et qui savent
pas ce que cela veut dire je vais
contrôler survivre assurément des macros
et sur votre votre
la scène principale c'est bien c'est
bien notamment la liste renaissance
puisque ça se joue aussi parfois par est
ce que stéphane bijoux qui le
réunionnais candidats sur cette liste là
qu'un dixième position qui si le sondage
devrez vous lui aussi entré est-ce que
c'est est ce que vous dites quelque part
et c'est bien sa farine en plus à
travaux à bruxelles où il maintenant ils
déferlent à petit il sera élu je pense
qu'il faut dire la vérité aux rayonnages
et au rennais ou joie de jouer du sauf
une grande révolution en france j'y
crois pas mais qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important est ce que c'est d'être
réunionnais ou est-ce que c'est là les
nerfs les dinos défend c'est d'être bon
d'être juste c'est ça le plus important
c'est pas d'être rayonner il ya des
traîtres parmi les rayonner il ya
beaucoup de traite est trop de traite
il y en a qui trahissent la population
réunionnaise que ce soit à l'assemblée
nationale mais aussi dans les instances
dissidents que ce soit la région
département ou dans les conseils
municipaux
donc il suffit pas d'être rayonner il
faut être bon tout simplement moi
monsieur stéphane bijoux n'a pas été
désigné par les réunionnais monsieur
younous omarjee a été désigné par les
rayonner passé fin de bijoux il a été
désigné par équipes désignées palais
rayonné lors de sa désignation en tant
que candidat en 2014 a été élu il était
non s'ils étaient sur une liste de la
région pas pas du pc c'est une liste de
rassemblement
il n'y avait pas que le pc y avait aussi
d'autres représentants des autres outre
mer besson sont d'accord que son mandat
précédent
il le doit bien au pcr il n'est là je la
succès des règles
il a succédé à élie hoarau ya pas de
traîtrise baissière pas du tout c'est le
peuple qui vote et ne peut pas désigner
lui nous sommes à j comme député
européen
aujourd'hui moi personnellement j'ai
quitté aussi le gt au pca j'ai quitté je
ne regrette pas mais j'ai rien de mal à
dire j'ai réellement la dir vis-à-vis du
pcr parce que moi je fais pas tirer sur
deux listes séparées contre oui mais ça
n'exclut pas le respect et moi je prends
toujours le respect vous savez j'ai eu
des amis aujourd'hui j'ai les 50 p mais
aucun moment vous allez entendre
m'entends dire il était comme s'il était
comme ça et cetera et cetera
donc il faut toujours respecter le pc a
joué un rôle extrêmement important dans
l'histoire de la réunion
heureusement qu'il ya eu le pc à la
réunion parce que sinon je serais en
syrie dans une situation encore pire
aujourd'hui et pas le ps et le pc à
jouer ce rôle
face aux ultras face à la droite dure et
et cela il faut il faut avoir du respect
pose la levée c'est aujourd'hui et dont
fait liste commune avec le pcf parti
communiste français les tentatives de
rassemblement
le pcf génération en place publique
le ps toute la gauche française partage
de son côté vous vous dites est ce que
vous dites vous ferment ou la france ont
soumis ça ne regarde pas parce qu'on n'a
pas envie d'être étiqueté de gauche
c'est ce clivage là où est ce que vous
dites pas c'est vendredi tout cet
ensemble je sais pas très honnêtement je
ne sais pas si c'est dommage ça aurait
été bien c'est pas bien que ces terrains
sera je suis pas là dedans mais moi je
suis pour avancer aujourd'hui moi je
soutiens une somme aj je soutiens la
liste de la france est soumis ça ne veut
pas dire que je suis d'accord à 100%
avec les orientations de la france a
soumis jeudi c'est le meilleur parmi les
autres et de toute façon il y aura deux
réunionnais député européen au soir du
26 / a pas de doute il faut
la vérité aux réunionnais je rappelle
julie pontalba c'est une personne que je
connais je laime bien et les gentils
tout cela elle sera pas élu il est
possible au vu des chiffres sauf
événement exceptionnel parce que mais
j'y crois pas parce que les sondages
sont reste des sondages loin on rappelle
la règle pour nos auditeurs
il faut 5 % c'est pour avoir des
angoisses et mr 5% on a tout de suite ce
qui lui laisse une famille alors voilà
près tout mais vous savez très bien que
l sera pas élue elle même le sait
maintenant elle elle aujourd'hui elle
défend une position des principes
maintenant il faut moi j'appelle les
réunionnaises et réunionnais à voter
massivement pour mieux nous sommes à j
ai une sommation quatrième position la
france est soumise dans les sondages
c'est 8 9 10 peut-être aux poissons aux
plus basses et me plaçant il sera élu
younous omarjee donc il faut passer un
message fort au président de la
république et à l'europe
plusieurs à deux voix sur le nom de
younousse omarjee de la liste manon
aubry l'a 10 françaises soumises plus il
sera en position de force
c'est là non je prends ton ces derniers
jours la question de la proximité entre
des électeurs voire des militants de la
france insoumise et du rassemblement
s'est posé avec ce que cet élu de la
région lyonnaise qui a quitté la france
musique aujourd'hui à voter pour très
clairement que tout oppose nationale et
la france
insoumise est ce que vous vous imaginez
comprenez vous que des militants des
électeurs puissent passer dans l'autre
est ce que ce qui lui avoir une
proximité dans la méthode
le seul plan dans l'hexagone c'est très
idéologique le vote front front national
c'est extrêmement idéologique à la
réunion c'est totalement différent c'est
pas idéologique à la réunion c'est la
colère c'est l'expression qui consiste à
dire il faut tout renversé il faut
renverser la table donc et on le voit
d'une élection à l'autre voir le front
national peut passer de 20-25 poisson à
2 3 poissons en très peu de temps donc
c'est pas un vote idéologique c'est
totalement différent et c'est encore
quand même à derrière petit évier pour
vous et pour moi je connais des gens qui
adhèrent pas du tout aux idées ils
disent jamais autant pour voir comment
pourrait il votera pour vous je sais pas
moi je respecte les gens peut-être qu'on
n'arrive pas à bien expliquer aussi et
peut-être c'est à nous de revoir notre
façon d'expliquer les choses les gens le
défap être confiance en la classe
politique et après je reviens ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure le rôle des
médias aussi quelle est la
responsabilité des médias dans une
élection quand un conseiller régional
appel à vous quitte la france est soumis
à potes à voter le front national sur
parmi les milliers les un élu conseiller
régional et donc on voit quand même
c'est monté en épingle
on utilise ça pour cassé brisé
la cible c'est quand même la française
ni soumises et jean luc mélenchon à la
réunion il y en a qui démissionne ou
passe d'un camp à l'autre
en fait il n'ya presque pas de bruit si
demain vous appeler à voter pour le pour
le rassemblement national je vous assure
que je suis député bruit je suis député
je suis pas conseiller régional oui mais
on ne faut pas confondre non mais non
même échelle même un député même un
conseiller municipal et conseiller
régional
dans l'hexagone ne vaut pas plus qu'un
député à la réunion qui avait appelé à
voter les titres c'est fini belabbas
adieu la question se pose quand même nom
de cette proximité vous même vous dis
non
la question pour moi ce ce monsieur je
ne connais pas mais quand on passe de la
france est soumise au rassemblement
national au front national il ya autre
chose que la ligne idéologique il ya
forcément autre chose c'est quoi vous
savez que à ce niveau
quant à ce stade des responsabilités à
ce niveau un politique il ya des gens
qui nous dépasse c'est même pas la peine
d'essayer de comprendre il faut
réfléchir il faut analyser
il faut tirer les enseignements mais
permettez moi de vous dire que c'est pas
idéologique
si c'est très éloigné la ligne du front
national et la ligne de la france et
smith est très éloignée en très peu de
temps peut pas passer d'un camp à
l'autre
donc il ya forcément autre chose c'était
ça ma question c'est est-ce et il faut
vous êtes un homme libre il n'y a pas de
pas de la tranquillité oscille entre vos
deux entre je vais vous dire c'est très
clair moi j'ai eues on m'a contacté
aussi propres à ces d'un camp à l'autre
mais c'est pas idéologique en vous
privez pas vous essayer de vous
convaincre sur le programme sur le
projet on utilise d'autres moyens pour
essayer de vous convaincre
mais avec jean hugues ratenon ça ne
marche pas je suis devant qui peuplent
qui venez vous des marchés mais je ne
veux pas donner de noms je vous dis
d'important pour la transparence dans
l'histoire de france depuis la
préhistoire
depuis très longtemps il ya eu déjà eu
déjà des traites et on sait dès fois il
suffit de regarder quelques films préval
odiah qui qui est nouveau adroit que
vous démarchez à droite
voilà très à droite très à droite et la
droite
votre adversaire construire votre
adversaire 7
c'est le libéralisme tel qu'il est
incarnée par la politique ed marinaro
c'est aussi le nationalisme qui est
prônée par ben écoutez moi je suis
citoyen du monde
je suis réunionnais du côté de ma mère
des gens qui venaient de rodrigues et si
on gratte un petit peu d'afrique de
l'inde
du côté de mon père de l'inde les gens
qui sont venus presque forcé à la
réunion en tant qu'esclave et en tant
qu'engagé automatiquement je suis
citoyen du monde et donc on ne peut pas
s'enfermer
il faut avoir cette ouverture sur le
monde et de toutes façons la terre bouge
et il y aura les pubs bouge
il ya des mouvements de population donc
il faudra se préparer à accueillir et se
préparer à se faire qu il ya aussi pas
dot
il ya des rayonner partout dans le monde
comme bien d'autres qui viennent ici on
ne peut pas dire on s'enferme et puis
c'est bon c'est très égoïste son
comportement et c'est irrespectueux
aussi vis-à-vis de la terre et la
planète et de la race humaine aussi donc
je dis toujours mes amis religieux que
quelle que soit la religion ont pris les
dieux mélèdje viennent d'où parce que
c'est pas trahir cédulas et de dire que
on s'enferme sur soi même donc il faut
avoir cette capacité d'ouverture mais en
même temps exigé ainsi qu'on respecte
les règles sur les territoires alors
j'explique aux assauts sur ce sujet de
l'immigration dans votre rang de la
liste
la france est soumise il est clairement
dit comme objectif de garantir le droit
d'asile accueillir dignement les
sections oblige
des financements européens on permettra
aux états qui le souhaitent de
s'exonérer m'y attendais règle au céret
d'austérité européenne garantir aux
fondamentaux et à l'asile interdit le
placement en centre de rétention de
mineurs et leurs familles ça veut dire
concrètement par exemple pour la réunion
il faut améliorer l'accueil parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya des dossiers qui sont
âprement doute y arriverons il faut
améliorer cet accueil
il faut il faut mieux à lire c'est ce
que je suis je fais partie des rares
élus s'il ya eu d'autres qui se sont
prononcés moi je me suis prononcé là
dessus il faut pas tiens la sauce
comprendre et d'ailleurs on a compris un
peu là quand on a vu les attentats les
des dizaines de morts etc etc
on a vu l'horreur ce qui se passe là bas
et c'est là qu'il ya quoi il ya on a eu
un début de prise de conscience des
réunionnaises et des réunionnais on ne
pourra pas accueillir de ceux qui
viennent
la réunion n'est pas en capacité de les
accueillir
ça va déstabiliser la société rennaise
dont pouvoir à la chose qu'est ce qui se
passe et comment aider
comment améliorer son fai d'ingérence
comment améliorer les choses
ça c'est de la politique internationale
maintenant quand quelqu'un arrive à
votre porte
il faut l'accueillir on ne fait pas on
claque pas comme ça la porte quelqu'un
qui a faim quelqu'un qui a soif on lui
donne à boire on lui donne à manger mais
on le dit aussi
je ne peux pas vous garder tout temps je
vous garde un jeu du joueur après faudra
trouver autre solution il faut bien
appeler un l'être humain on ne peut pas
importer des animaux dans de bonnes
conditions et on ne respecte pas l'être
humain il faut respecter tous les êtres
y compris les êtres humains de votre vie
dion économiques et sociales de l'europe
parce que c'était moqueur du du sujet le
prendre la liste la force sont soumises
promet de faire respecter la
souveraineté des peuples de lutter
contre la fuite en avant gayral c'est
vraiment au coeur de l'autre de votre
d'autres projets avec cette question qui
revient reste qu'il faut dénoncer les
traitements actuels est-ce qu'ils
arrêtent la difficulté pour les dénoncer
faudrait tous d'accord unités et c'est
donc très très compliqué le plan b qui à
une époque il aime dire puisque c'est
comme si ces occidentaux qu'il n'est
plus votre souris vous dites il faut
désobéir aux traités aux règles qui
serait pas acceptable
je suis un insoumis depuis ma naissance
et c'est l'héritage même de mes parents
je ne suis pas c'est pas devenu insoumis
après la création de la france est
soumise moi c'est un héritage
face à l'oppression face à la politique
qui consiste à rabaisser une partie de
la population par rapport à d'autres et
et en même temps mon côté un somme il
résistants indignée mme oblige aussi à
dire je ne maîtrise pas tout c'est vrai
qu'à la réunion les politiques les élus
maîtrise tous les sujets ils sont
tellement bons tellement extraordinaire
qui maîtrise tout ils ont réponse à tout
faire pour sa santé
et moi je vous dis très sincèrement je
ne maîtrise pas tout l'europe c'est très
technique c'est très pointu et c'est
pour cette raison il faut voter pour
younousse omarjee et donc moi c'est sur
les principes
je veux aborder ces questions c'est sur
l'aspect humain qu'est ce qu'on fait de
l'humain est-ce que c'est l'agent qui
domine où l'humain domine c'est ça la
question
et ça sert à rien d'aller essayer
d'expliquer techniquement comment on
fait et c'est important de voir comment
est-ce qu'on parlement quelle marge de
manoeuvre les politiques
de réunion 1ère malheureusement de
réunion 1ère radio malheureusement
décédé aujourd'hui ils me posaient la
question je me rappelle puis en quelle
année
je crois que c'était en 2011 ou 2012 il
me poser la question c et puis il a
rigolé il me disait ben écoute comment
régler le problème de la cherté de la
vie et ma réponse était il suffit
d'aimer son prochain
il suffit de respecter lot des mélodies
et de considérer que tout le monde à
vivre dans la société demande doit
trouver sa place et ne pas tout accaparé
ça veut dire croire ça veut dire arrêtez
avec les abus arrêtez avec les mages
abusif
il faut une entreprise est là pour faire
des bénéfices mais pas pour écraser le
peuple de toute façon si vous prenez
tout il y aura plus donc ça va bloquer
donc sur l'aspect économique à l'europe
nous voulons nous voulons une europe
plus humaine une europe qui tienne
compte véritablement de l'aspect humain
aujourd'hui c'est une europe des
capitalistes quand on met des normes
européennes pas tout et on tue les
petites entreprises régionales
comment les entreprises rien et c'est là
il faut protéger nous entrons paix il
faut mettre des règles il faut être
d'avoir une vision régionale aussi dans
justement dans justement quelques années
parce que bon on entend les détails de
du fond selon lui mais les reflets
région pas faire réunion on place un peu
à part est ce que vous serez pour qu'on
aille vers plus d'autonomie de ces rup
ce qu'il faut qu'on décide plus de
choses localement est ce que dans le
lien qu'on arrête le rock
ce qu'il faut ce qui vous ont conduit ce
qu'il faut faire évoluer
comment est-ce que disons que c'est là
c'est important dé ce qui peut expliquer
aux gens et vous l'avez fait et c'est là
moi j'apprécie les journalistes quand il
pose une question
mais il explique et vous avez très très
justement dit que la réunion est dans
l'europe
mais la réunion est une région
ultrapériphérique ce qu'on appelle les
rues couramment ça veut dire qu'on est
dans l'europe
mme avec un statut particulier donc une
prise en compte de nos spécificités de
notre éloignement de notre situation
géographique des notions donc les nôtres
situation économique cite une vidéo ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il ya un p d'autonomie
donc le mot autonomie ne doit pas faire
peur puisqu'on est déjà augmenté je
pense qu'il faut l'augmenter
il faut augmenter justement ce niveau
d'autonomie pour prendre en compte nos
spécificités parce que nos petites
entreprises rayonnait ne peuvent pas
faire face aux multinationales a
aujourd'hui on lance des appels d'offres
à caractère européenne
mais comment l'entreprise rennaise à
répondre à l'appel d'offres quand vous
avez des des grandes entreprises qui
viennent avec des critères beaucoup plus
intéressant que les sociétés
réunionnaises
quand vous avez une poule une production
de 9
on dit il faut des normes pour les yeux
et sait comment le bogavac sur des trois
poules la balle et ça met son sens
poulailler au nomme donc il faut tenir
compte des spécificités et aussi par
rapport justement à la libre échange à
la libre circulation des biens et des
personnes et on s'est battu contre
le la directive bolkestein par exemple
comment allons-nous faire face avec un
taux de chômage aussi élevé chômage de
masse et durable qui trouve pas qu'ils
trouvent pas de solution comment allons
nous supporter la venue des travailleurs
portugais où il y en a actuellement
donc c'est cela il faut tenir compte il
faut tenir compte aussi de de l'octroi
de mer vous savez le 30 mai à la base
c'était le droit de poids et c'était une
taxe qu'on la marchandise arrive à la
réunion ont taxé la marchandise pour pas
venir écraser la production locale mais
où ça ne construis d'automobiles à la
réunion pourquoi il y à l'octroi de bien
celles sur les véhicules qui arrivent on
ne construit pas pour fêter les
collectivités pour faire vivre c'est ce
que j'appelle moi le troisième le 13ème
mois dé mer et c'est pas l'octroi de
main c'est le 3d mer et donc moi ça les
éleveurs et qui permet aussi de dons
d'objets qui permet de mai mais de quoi
de taxer les réunionnaises et les
réunionnais pour lui crier le client la
politique clientélisme aussi pour le
13ème mois dé mer donc et s'ils
réfléchissaient ces élus là essayer de
trouver d'autres solutions
essayez de trouver une fiscalité
locale et si non ils préfèrent la
facilité mais ça va beaucoup plus loin
plus qu'on taxe aussi des produits
fabriqués à la réunion
donc le droit de poids qui consistait à
protéger la production locale
aujourd'hui s'applique aussi à la
production locale avec la bénédiction
des élus mais mais c'est quoi ça et
c'est pour cette raison que il est est
bonne nous allons élire yussoise il sera
reconduit dans son poste de député et si
nous souhaitons le maximum de voix sur
son nom
c'est pour lui permettre aussi parce que
le mode d'élection européenne a changé
avant ont voté sur la région maintenant
c'est une élection nationale
donc il sera pas élu député pour la
réunion mais pour le national et c'est
pour cette raison depuis sera de voir
rayonner plus on pourra imposer qu'ils
agissent plus pour la réunion et pour le
national y aura d'autres députés pour
faire le travail le travail là bas
donc je voudrais qu'on parle de
l'écologie vous avez mentionné au tout
début cette émission vous avez dit
l'importance que ça fait pour vous le
respect de la nature
concrètement l'europe
c'est des normes vous l'avez dit parfois
on al'impression vu d'ici certains
pourraient avoir le sentiment que les
normes européennes de respect de
l'environnement et nous empêche de vivre
et de continuer à produire quand on l'a
toujours fait et elles sont plus
contraignantes que je faisais ce qu'il
faut là aussi et d'autonomie qui nous
permette d'échapper à ces règles de
pensées sont avec eux dans son aspect
auquel il faut beaucoup plus loin on n'a
pas le choix
toute la politique européenne nationale
et régionale doit être basée sur avoir
comme base la protection de la planète
la protection des espèces la protection
de l'être humain on n'a pas le choix
sinon nous allons vers l'extinction de
la race humaine
on est parti ça et désespèrent des
centaines espère le 10 mai le promesse
que le lobby financier la finance
l'agent le fric le pognon domine trop la
société donc nous aujourd'hui nous
disons il faut absolument protéger la
planète et est par exemple dans la
psychologie sociologie d'autres preuve
de beaucoup de programmes européens et
sur l'agriculture est une tradition du
glyphosate
c'est pour ça que je veux dire le combat
de younousse omarjee le combat de la
pause et tout de suite les diffuseurs
non là c'est fini tout jeune il faut les
aider il faut les accompagner
quand on dit c'est là le problème qu'est
ce qu'on dit a nommé si on arrête le
glyphosate les agriculteurs vont mourir
mais oui mais et si on n'arrête pas tous
nos moeurs les agriculteurs et nous tout
le monde y compris les agriculteurs
beaucoup plus vite parce qu'ils sont en
contact direct avec le glyphosate et on
les a menti pendant des années des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années on n'a
pas dit des fois on n'a pas mentir mais
on n'a pas dit la vérité aux
agriculteurs et ils sont en train de
s'empoisonner
et ils n'ont pas eu indirectement
inconsciemment la population la réunion
fait partie des départements français
qui importe le plus de glyphosate je
crois qu'on dernier en deuxième position
je crois lo ré lyonnaise
contaminé de glyphosate est donc le
combat
c'est là aussi il faut stopper le
glyphosate le plus rapidement possible
et accompagner nos agriculteurs il fait
juste en agriculture est ce qu'il faut
aller aussi vers la pensée l'après
quinze jours il faut penser à tout mais
aujourd'hui la préparation est ce que
l'après canne à sucre pur sucre
alimentaire
mais l'après can à sic c'est c'est aussi
la can comme d'autres choses une chose
énergie on peut transformer il ya
plusieurs façons de transformer la can
il ya le sud il ya l'énergie
il ya aussi les filles qu'on peut
fabriquer des matériaux etc
donc on aura besoin de l'europe sur ce
dossier la réunion aura besoin de
l'europe la réunion c'est 2,3 milliards
d'euros à peu près des financements
européens
la réunion c'est le fonds social
européen fse la réunion c'est le feder
le feader
la réunion s'est tous ces fonds ce qui
arrive dans les caisses maintenant et il
nous sommes à j s'est battu pour le
maintien
parce que c'est pas facile c'est très
tendu au niveau européen et donc il
s'est battu pour le maintien des fonds
pas seulement pour la région pour
d'autres régions aussi et notamment la
protection des régions est rattrapé et
périphérie maintenant c'est cet agent
arrive à la réunion
maintenant est-ce qu'il est bien gérée
ou pas il ya des efforts il faut
améliorer la gestion des fonds européens
est ce que c'est pour manger par la
région présents moi je dis oui mais avec
des élus responsables
vous savez moi je dis toujours des amis
c'est pas parce que la maison cool qu'il
faut raser la maison nous faut changer
l'école donc attention ne pas tout raser
ne pas tout casser mais il faut
améliorer toujours améliorer les outils
et 11 minutes
en haut de votre
positionnement à vous vous êtes
tellement député national avait dit vous
allez vous étiez comme d'hab municipales
à venir est pas au bout de votre mandat
de député c'est assumer vous m'avez dit
avant l'émission qui aura que des
questions sur le rôle comme une orange
est inutile
je vous ai dit je vous autorise à poser
des questions sur les municipales et
régionales sur la politique réunionnaise
ou un v10 non c'est seulement je parle
voilà mais comme je vais respecter ce
que vous mon accord donc on parlera des
on parlera de votre site et actualité
politique et je vais lâcher toutes les
questions chez les municipales
régionales et la politique c'est bien
noté merci à vous joindre à notre avis
tu essaies noté 6 versions les
municipales je pense que ça va ça va
beaucoup nous occuper les municipales
dans les mois qui viennent merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on va
c'est dimanche c'est un scrutin à un
tour juste dire que les démissions
commença à bras panon judith on aura des
municipales merci je vais faire à temps